if a moment when a long term interest
rate of 2.2% and a construction
unemployment rate that is in double
digits if that kind of moment is not the
right moment to fix Kennedy Airport I
don't know when that moment will ever
come we as a country have been
chronically under investing in
infrastructure for a long time almost
never in the history of the United
States since the Second World War have
we been devoting as lower proportion of
our national output to investments in
infrastructure as we are today and you
see the consequences in potholes in our
highways you see it in occasional bridge
collapses you see it in the fact that we
have thousands of schools across the
country where paint is chipping off the
walls even as we tell our children that
education is the most important thing
you see it in the fact that we have an
air traffic control system in the United
States that relies on vacuum tube
technology and where it's almost
impossible to get anyone to do a repair
who's under 60 years of age because they
don't have any contact with the relevant
technologies you see it in the fact that
in a variety of wireless and broadband
technologies the United States lags a
number of other countries so I think
there's an enormous opportunity for
productive infrastructure investments
and certainly at a moment when the
long-term interest rate is so low
there's a great deal of investment on
which we could earn a social return very
much in excess of the social cost
you